bueno como decís tenemos mucha evidencia
de su presencia en organismos organismos
terrestres organismos marinos y también
tenemos mucha evidencia de los efectos
dañinos o el etéreos que pueden ocurrir
sobre estos organismos las
evidencias sobre los efectos y la
relación causa-efecto sobre los humanos
es mucho menor recién estamos en lo que
es la clínica humana en la infancia no
es una etapa inicial hay mucho por hacer
pero con el obstáculo que con el Humano
poco podemos poco se puede experimentar
hay algunos estudios epidemiológicos
ahora clínicos en desarrollo unos 15 a
nivel mundial Pero lo que sí sabemos es
que los microplásticos que están en en
la biosfera que están en el aire la
atmósfera y en la geosfera están
entrando al cuerpo humano y están
ingresando a diferentes tejidos
Cuáles son otras principales fuentes de
exposición humana a estos microplásticos
bueno por supuesto hay dos principales
que son la vida digestiva a través de
los alimentos y la vía respiratoria a
través de lo que estamos respirando
vivimos en un mundo lleno de partículas
todo el tiempo estamos respirando algún
tipo de partícula No ya sea polvo ya sea
polen y entre ellos hemos sumado en las
últimas tres o cuatro décadas a los
microplásticos la vía respiratoria es
sin duda una de las principales vías de
exposición las pequeñas partículas de 1
a 5 milímetros de un micrón a 5
milímetros que son los micro plásticos
pueden llegar a los sitios más profundos
de los pulmones así se los ha detectado
por ejemplo en algunos estudios reportes
postoperatorios y en algunas autopsias
existen y están alojados permanentemente
en el fondo de los pulmones hay teorías
que hoy nos dicen que además pueden
traslocar al torrente sanguíneo y de ahí
a distribuirse a diferentes órganos del
cuerpo Por supuesto que la vía digestiva
funciona de una manera similar si están
en los alimentos están en la miel si
están en el agua envasada si están en
los peces y otros alimentos marinos por
supuesto pueden ingresar por vía
digestiva a través de las paredes
intestinales